>> Tucker: THAT PAPER IS
DISGUSTING.
RICHARD, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FORMER NIGHT LINE HOST TED
COPEL SAID SOMETHING THAT WAS
TRUE.
HE SAID THE PRESS HAS ABANDONED
OBJECTIVITY AND PURSUING A
POLITICAL VENDETTA.
>> I'M TERRIBLY CONCERNED WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" THESE DAYS OR THE
"WASHINGTON POST" THESE DAYS.
WE AREN'T TALKING ABOUT "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" OF 50 YEARS AGO.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
"WASHINGTON POST" OF 50 YEARS
AGO.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I BELIEVE
HAVE, IN FACT, DECIDED AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS BAD FOR THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME WORKED WITH TED FOR
MANY YEARS AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
I DON'T THINK OF HIM AS A
CONSERVATIVE FIGURE AT ALL.
BUT HE JUST SAID SOMETHING THAT
I THINK MANY ON THE LEFT WILL
HATE.
IS IT TRUE AND WHY DID HE SAY
IT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S UNMISTAKABLY TRUE, I
DID WORK WITH HIM FOR MANY
YEARS.
HE IS OLD SCHOOL MUCH AS I AM.
WE COME OUT OF THE SAME
TRADITION, WHICH IS NEUTRALITY
IN NEWS COVERAGE, OPINIONS
RESERVED FOR COLUMNISTS AND
EDITORIAL WRITER AND BROADCAST
JOURNALISM YOU HAVE CERTAIN
COMMENTATORS AND CORRESPONDENTS
WHO COVER THE NEWS.
THOSE LINES OF SEPARATION HAVE
BECOME INCREASINGLY BLURRED AND
IN THE AGE OF TRUMP, AS HE
SUGGESTED, THEY'VE GONE
COMPLETELY OUT THE WINDOW
BECAUSE OF THE SENSE AMONG
JOURNALISTS THAT THE ELECTION
OF DONALD TRUMP CONSTITUTED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND THEIR
DUTY AS PATRIOTS TO RESIST IT
AND TO DO ALL THEY COULD TO
UNDO THIS PRESIDENCY, WHICH
THEY HAVE TRIED TO DO AND WE
SEE IT REFLECTED CONSTANTLY.
>> Tucker: I SUPPOSE WHAT I
FIND SO UPSETTING ABOUT IT IS
HOW INDIRECT AND DISHONEST IT
IS.
OPINION PEOPLE ARE STRAIGHT
FORWARD.
RACHEL MADDOW.
SHE SAYS EXACTLY WHO SHE IS.
NO MISLEADING ANYBODY BEING AN
OPINION PERSON.
WHY SHOULDN'T NEWS PEOPLE WHO
DECIDE TO BECOME ACTIVISTS SAY
SO OUT LOUD?
>> WELL, I AGREE WITH THAT BUT
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS
WATERGATE REALLY IS A FACTOR
HERE BECAUSE AT THAT MOMENT,
WHICH WAS THE MOST EXCITING,
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT
IN MODERN JOURNALISTIC HISTORY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THESE TWO YOUNG REPORTERS SEEN
AS BRINGING DOWN A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAD ALL BEEN TOLD THE FOURTH
ESTATE -- NONE OF US HAD EVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
IT WAS REMARKABLE AND GLAMOROUS
AND CELEBRATED IN MOVIES, THE
SUBJECT OF ENDLESS BOOKS AND SO
ON AND IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
MOMENT.
IT CREATED AN ATMOSPHERE THAT
JOURNALISTS WANT TO RELIVE THIS.
HERE COMES A TARGET MORE
UNPOPULAR THAT RICHARD NIXON IN
THE PERSON OF DONALD TRUMP AND
THEY'VE GONE ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS.
BACK IN THOSE DAYS THE
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING ON
WATERGATE WAS SOLID.
BUT WHEN DONALD TRUMP GAVE HIS
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS THIS
YEAR THE HEADLINE -- THE
HEADLINE IN THE NEXT DAY'S
"WASHINGTON POST", BANNER
HEADLINE SAID A DISCORDANT
APPEAL FOR UNITY.
THAT IS AN OPINION.
YOU DIDN'T USED TO SEE THAT IN
HEADLINES IN THE NEWS PAGES OF
ANY NEWSPAPERS LET ALONE THE
"WASHINGTON POST".
AS TED SAID, THINGS HAVE